- [Voiceover] In our last video,
we started looking at this speech by
Franklin Delano Roosevelt which he gave
at his innaguration in March of 1933.
We took some time to just identify what
was happening in this speech
and also the context of this speech,
coming at the height of
the Great Depression.
- [Voiceover] Now we're gonna
dive deeper into our textual
analysis and explore the soucre,
figure out what is going on
with Roosevelt's language
and what he's trying to say
and what his biases are.
- [Voiceover] Let's get a
little more into what else goes
on in this speech, not just the very
famous opening paragraph.
We start here with
saying people are facing
the grim problem of existence,
and a foolish optimist can
deny the dark realities
of the moment, and
then what comes next?
- [Voiceover] Let's hear
all this in context.
Yet our distress comes from
no failure of substance.
We are stricken by no plague of locusts,
compared with the perils which
our forefathers conquered,
because they believed and were not afraid,
we still have much to be thankful for.
Nature still offers her bounty and human
efforts have multiplied.
Plenty is at our doorstep,
but a generous use of it languishes
in the very sight of the supply.
Primarily this is because the rulers
of the exchange of
mankind's goods have failed
through their own stubbornness
and their own incompetence.
Having admitted their failure
and abdicated, practices of
the unscrupulous money changers
stand indicted in the
court of public opinion,
rejected by the hearts and minds of man.
Restoration calls however,
not for changes in ethics alone.
This nation asks for
action and action now.
What's interesting about this paragraph
is that there's a lot of Bible stuff going
on in here.
There's a lot of biblical references
that serve to do I think a lot of work
for Roosevelt in this inaugural address.
- [Voiceover] As you talked,
I just underlined the things
that really stood out
to me as maybe kind of
the heart of what he was saying,
and you're saying these are
like Biblical references.
What do you mean by that?
- [Voiceover] Some of them are.
When we're talking about plague of locusts
and money changers specifically,
we're looking at old and
new testament references
respectively, in fact,
later in this speech,
he refers to money changers
being chased out of our nation's
temple which is a deliberate
reference to the New Testament.
- [Voiceover] This is very grand.
We love to hear this speech so much,
because it has that kind of ringing
of authenticity in a way that maybe
a modern speech does not.
- [Voiceover] Some of
that authenticity comes
through association with ethic literature
and the Bible.
He's making these illusions
to great Biblical events.
Like the plague of locusts
being visited upon Egypt
which was like a great
and terrible plague,
and he's using that as a counter point
to the misery of the present moment.
He's saying, look,
things could be worse.
We could be ancient Egypt in the Bible,
and locusts could be
eating all of our crops.
Things are bad, but it's not like
God himself is willing
destruction upon us.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I think this is also
another one of the
really interesting things
about the great depression.
It's true that there were farm failures
during the dust bowl,
but on the whole it's
not like people stopped producing food.
This wasn't a famine.
What it was was a crisis
of confidence where
prices went down significantly,
and so farmers could not
make a living on their crops.
It's not that they didn't have food.
It's that they didn't have money,
and I also feel like there's a different
aspect to the reason that
he uses this biblical
language here, and I think that's because
it's very authoritative.
When you stand up in
front of a group of people
and Roosevelt has this powerful voice
which really resonates with people,
and you speak like a preacher would speak.
It says, this is a man of authority.
This is a man who perhaps
is in touch with the moral
authority associated
with the Christian Bible.
- [Voiceover] Sure, for a very long time,
authority was kind of
correlated with your ability
to quote chapter and verse.
I mean we're talking
about a man who is just
put his hand on a Bible in order to
swear himself in.
- [Voiceover] It really makes him seem
not only like he knows
what he's talking about,
but also that he's got a
handle on the situation.
- [Voiceover] What we're
saying that by harnessing
the language, he's trying
to harness the authority
that people have invested
in the church by using the
language of the church.
- [Voiceover] What we're doing here,
I might call step three
which is to identify
how an argument is made.
We're looking at his rhetorical strategies
and seeing how they're
effective or in perhaps
another case, not effective
in conveying his opinion,
and I say opinion.
At this point, what would
we say that his opinion of
the Great Depression is?
- [Voiceover] That it's
specific people's fault,
that it is at the fault of not just this
wave of panic, but on a
count of some greedy people,
the unscrupulous money changers
and the rulers of the exchanges.
He's blaming bankers for
the great depression,
which I think is fair.
There's very little
regulation in the 1920s
that would prevent the kind of fraud
that could lead to a collapse of banking.
For example, insider
trading is not illegal,
and most people bought stocks on margin
which is a terrible idea
which means you only have
to put 10% of the value
of a bond down before you buy it,
which means that there's
a lot of theoretical
money floating around out
there that's not backed by
much real money.
- [Voiceover] That sounds
like a terrible idea.
- [Voiceover] It was a terrible idea.
- [Voiceover] It's like
buying stocks on credit.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] Oh, man.
- [Voiceover] His argument
is that first, things could
be worse.
Second of all, the reason things are bad
is because of these people.
Thing number three,
here's how we're going to
get back on track.
- [Voiceover] This is where
we get here at the end.
The nation asks for action,
and action now, which it says not only
a mention of how he's
going to get things done
but a covert poke at Herbert Hoover for
not doing much, and then he says,
our greatest primary task
is to put people to work.
Remember there's an
unemployment rate of 25%.
- [Voiceover] That is so many people.
- [Voiceover] Our current
unemployment rate is less
than 5% to give you an idea.
This is no unsolvable
problem if we face it wisely
and courageously.
it can be accomplished in part by direct
recruiting by the government itself,
treating the task as we
would treat the emergency
of a war, but at the same time,
through this employment,
accomplishing greatly
needed projects to stimulate
and reorganize the use
of our natural resources.
- [Voiceover] This is a radical idea.
- [Voiceover] It is a really radical idea,
and this is one reason why
historians love to study
the great depression
and the administration of
Franklin Delano Roosevelt,
because this is kind of
the decade where we threw
out the rulebook, and
I think what Roosevelt
is saying here is he was willing to try
anything to conquer the great depression,
and one of the things he tries is
bringing the government into the process
of giving people work.
We've got a sense of what he's arguing
and how he's arguing it.
Let's take a higher level look now.
Let's say step four is seeing
if you can analyze
the potential bias of a source,
and I wanna be clear that
all sources are biased.
I think a common misconception is that
if you're looking at a source,
it's either biased or it's not.
It's written by someone who has an agenda
or someone whose completely impartial,
and that is never the case.
- [Voiceover] What about a photograph?
If I take a photograph
of something or someone,
isn't that then objective rendering
of that person or object?
- [Voiceover] It certainly
shows what was there
at that moment in time,
but even photographers are making choices.
When you pick up a camera
and you take a picture
of a thing, you are taking a picture
of that thing and not something else,
which in itself a form of bias
to say I think this is
important or this is what I want
you to see.
- [Voiceover] Where we
put the frame is a choice.
The question is what is Roosevelt
not saying in this speech?
What is he not taking a photograph of?
What's just outside
the view of his camera?
- [Voiceover] And why is
he taking this photograph
of a speech?
When he sat down to write this, what was
motivating him?
And what are some of the perhaps even
less obvious factors
about why he makes the
argument that he does.
- [Voiceover] Obviously,
the man has a bias
in favor of his own politics.
These are his administrations, ideas.
He's going to be coming out in
favor of those very strongly.
- [Voiceover] FDR is a democrat.
There really haven't been many democrats
in office since before
the Lincoln administration
since the 1860s.
That's a new thing.
This is the popular base rejecting
Hoover and the Republican
party because of the Great Depression.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] He's bringing democratic
political ideas to the table here.
- [Voiceover] He's trying to make a case
for those political ideas in this speech.
He was elected by the majority
of American voters, but now
he has to make the case to
the rest of the United States.
He has to make a case to the people
that didn't elect him.
- [Voiceover] He's saying
that direct recruiting by
the government itself, government jobs,
having the powers as if
the depression were war,
that is a case for really
strong government intervention
which is a key stone
of the democratic party
compared to Republicans who generally
advocate for a smaller government.
He's saying this is what's gonna work.
The democratic platform
of using the government
in the economy and in social programs
is what's going to work to get us out
of this depression.
- [Voiceover] He's making
a big strong case for
federalism.
- [Voiceover] Exactly, what
I think is interesting though
here is that there's a lot he doesn't say,
and I think that's also important
to look at when you're
analyzing a primary source.
There's a lot that you could talk about,
but you make choices
about what to talk about
and what not to mention.
What could you say he
doesn't mention here?
- [Voiceover] He doesn't mention how
any of this is going to work.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I think
that's maybe the biggest
missing piece here.
This is broad strokes.
This is getting people on board,
but no where does he say, okay
here's exactly what I'm going to do.
Let me tell you how many dollars
I'm going to spend, how many people
I'm going to hire, what sort of cabinets
I'm going to create.
This is not a time for specifics he says.
This is almost more of an
inspirational speech to say
okay, I gotcha.
We've looked at the source.
We've analyzed it's rhetorical strategies,
and it's potential bias.
The last thing we might wanna do with this
is now think about how we
could use it as a source.
- [Voiceover] We're taking
this primary source,
and we're turning it
into a secondary source.
- [Voiceover] Right, so
say that you are sitting down to
write an essay about the Great Depression,
and you've gotta say, now can I use
Franklin Delano Roosevelt's inaugural
address to make my point in my essay?
Step five
let's say synthesize perhaps.
Using my big words,
as a tool for your own argument.
- [Voiceover] I would say
that this speech is the frame
that Roosevelt is putting
on the depression.
This is how he is creating the narrative
that he wants Americans to adopt
or he is identifying the
crisis and this is how
he wants people to see it.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, so this
might be a great primary source
to tell you about
Roosevelt's strategy or his
communication strategy.
What might it not be a
very good primary source
to help you make an agrument for?
- [Voiceover] It probably
wouldn't be a very good primary
source for the Republican legislative
response.
You might wanna go with
Senator Reid Smoot of Utah
for something like that.
- [Voiceover] Right, and it's
probably not a great source
for really diving into the
specifics of the new deal.
He doesn't say anything about the civilian
conservation corp.
He doesn't say anything
about the national recovery
administration.
This is not the nuts and
bolts of the new deal.
It's the grand idea behind it.
- [Voiceover] Right, he's
trying to sell the new deal.
- [Voiceover] It's I think,
a really powerful primary
source for understanding
the impetus behind
the new deal, but not the programs.
- [Voiceover] Sweet.
- [Voiceover] Alright, well
thank you for bringing your
sweet grammarian skills to the table
as we look at Roosevelt's speech.
- [Voiceover] My pleasure,
thank you for bringing
your sweet historian skills to the table.
- [Voiceover] Kim and David out.
- [Voiceover] Scholarly high five!